have you ever wondered why do we sleep  we sleep peacefully in our bedroom in a  cozy situation but think of a rabbit we  sleeping in the wild and he is more  vulnerable to the predators while he is  sleeping  it looks quite disadvantageous for him  yet sleeping behavior is well conserved  in animal kingdom  but why  it turns out sleep has certain  advantages sleep is not a state of  inactivity  in contrast scientists have found out  that sleep is quite activity rich  and recent research has shown that sleep  helps in memory consolidation our  temporary memory get transferred from  the hippocampus to the cortex during  sleep  and this is like memory transfer from  ram to the hard disk of a computer isn't  that interesting subscribe for more